العام الثاني على التوالي ترعى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
الاحتفاء باليوم العالمي للغه العربيه على
مدى يومين من الفعاليات الثقافيه
بحضور رئيس الجمعيات العامه ونائبه الامين
العام وكبار الدبلوماسيين في منظمه
الدوليه ففي 18 من ديسمبر عام 73
واعتمدت العربيه ضمن اللغات الرسميه الست
للامم المتحده وحدد هذا اليوم عام 2012
كيوم العالمي للاحتفاء بلغه الضاد
العالمي اللغه العربيه في مسارات عديده
التخطيطه والبرامج العلميه والثقافيه ولكن
انا نركز ضمن توجيهات سمو وزيره الثقافه
رئيس مجلس الامه العربيه على مسار اللغه
العربيه في المنظمات الدوليه
للسنه الثانيه في منظمه الامم المتحده همم
برامج متصله بمنظمه اليونسكو وبرامج قاعده
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي الى مش قريب جدا
في مباراه الدوليه الحديث لا يتحدثون هنا
عن اللغه العربيه واعداد مفرداتها التي
تتجاوز اضعاف مفردات اللغات الاخرى ولا
النحوها وصرفها وبيانها وشعرها ونترها
انما هم يتحدثون عن التعدد الثقافي
واللغوي والمسيره التاريخيه والرؤيه
المستقبليه للغه نجحت في بناء جسور
التواصل والمعارف
والتاخي بين الامم مسلم
الو سبيكر
الى قلبه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قال في اللغه العربيه
من الامم المتحده طلال الحاج العربي
[موسيقى]